bell
si le ponton qui s'est formé avec dell
c'est que ça marche toujours
oui enfin disons qu'on peut passer des
succès de julien clerc plus actuel que
les miennes coeur ses marques
il ya plusieurs générations qui chantent
la même chanson j'aime habiter sur des
nouvelles voilà ce que je veux voir les
nouveaux morceaux société bull lors des
120 jours c'est une parole de patrick
loiseau comme tt les paroles comme tout
les ballons vous êtes étrangères en
italie des caisses qui va vous arriver
maintenant
l'interview jugement dernier on a beau
chemin pendant les dinka
donc tu es mort ceci m'a tuer devant
dieu day as tu voler de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit ouais je les fais à cause de dos
qui est un livre qui fait rimer
châtiment bah oui parce que je me dis
est ce que je suis capable comme
raskolnikov ou est-ce que je vais
craquer moi j'ai craqué et j'ai dit à
maman mais c'est là justement croyez
qu'il était perdu et j'ai dit c'est là
et je les retrouve l argent coule donc
gipsy le brave comme des intrus copié
sur ton voisin en classe pendant les
compositions non non c'était plutôt les
voisins et vos pieds sur moi en toute
modestie
à tvo les tue enfermé tes camarades dans
les cabinets de l'école non mais je me
suis fait je me suis fait prendre avec
un camarade dans la cabane de l'école
ok parce que nous étions il y en a un
qui est portée aux chiottes
il a en jouer au bridge à l'école y
avait eu un problème de bridge sur le
mur et on est allés à deux procédés
résoudre les problèmes pas faire croire
ça aux profs c'est la stricte vérité
jamais fait de ma mère au plus tard un
portique l'arrêt de fumée derrière est
correct et thierry moi quand tu refuses
et au devoir conjugal en prétextant une
migraine
non mais si parfois fatigué day
c'était lui le jugement dernier as tu
déjà trompé ton compagnon dans la tête
et jamais
day as tu utilisé sa notoriété pour
séduire
pour peter kay as-tu consommer des
substances aphrodisiaques
on y prenons du plaisir c'était le
relogement des gendres s'en fait partie
sur un bon et tu vivras ensuite des
actes que la morale réprouve
brasles de quel pays regrettes-tu
d'avoir accepté que ta mère soit
euthanasié
ou alors j'ai eu des doutes mais j'ai
des doutes c'est même pour ça qu'on a
fait autopsié quand on a vu qu'il y
avait vraiment des métastases partout et
bien non on apparaître regretté
relatives à la vérité il est là alors
on connaît l'histoire du mec justement
qui meurent qui a ré décent et à droite
il ya une salle événements il veut par
tous vraiment comment s'imaginer en
faire iago geremek à manger avec des
énormes pétards il a le droit de choisir
à toi alors évidemment il s'agit là ça
avec des noms me paie pas et s'allonger
prend une lampée tard il est quelqu'un
du feu non ça c'est l'autre sage